avouez que la jaquette est belle c'est
très très joli et c'est un très beau
texte très beau texte qui bien émaillée
par de belles images
l'enfant qui n'avait jamais vu de fleurs
textes d'andrée anne gratton images
d'oussama mézères et c'est paru tout
récemment sont mes invités qu'il était
aujourd'hui bonjour bonjour bienvenue
comment une idée andréanne d'écrire ce
texte bien écoutez je l'expliqué dans le
préambule du livre parce que c'était
quelque chose d'assez particulier
c'est une idée que j'ai eu dix ans avant
la parution du livre comment j'avais
entendu louise arbour qui alors autant
faire si nous étions devenus pour les
droits humains qui avait dit je l'avais
vu d'ailleurs au téléjournal de radio
canada l'été aux abords d'un camp de
réfugiés
et elle parle à des journalistes elle
s'est penchée vers une petite fille
elodie aux journalistes vous rendez vous
compte que cet enfant là n'a jamais vu
une fleur de sa vie s'offre un peu ça
m'a frappé beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
tellement que j'ai gardé cette image
lointaine longtemps avant de réussir à
imaginez une histoire d'espoir autour de
cette rafle parce que de la fleur c'est
la marque d'espoir quand on fait
attention
oui c'est la marque d'espoir c'est aussi
quelque chose qu'on prend pour acquis
on ne peut pas imaginer qu'un enfant
jamais vu de fleurs de sa vie à l'âge de
5 ans ou alors c'était c'est beau les
biens les farces et très très beau oui
c'est une image très forte où sa mère
comment es tu arrivé il ce texte dans
votre vie des illustratrices vous moi j
ai mangé je connais on a plein de très
petits chez moi j'ai d'origine libanaise
puis la région et toujours on son et feu
et puis c'est arrivé je dis c'est une
bonne occasion de de données comme un
peu de mon perspectives concernant ce
sujet là puis c'est ici j'imagine buteur
ouais quoi
ouais lucide sans lapinot et en lin
directrice de collection aux éditions de
la bagnole
oui parce que j'ai déjà fait des livres
avec avec eux puis c'est ça mon style
les a touchés par les mois de ce style
de ce secret se regarde
ouais c'était mouillé c'est toujours
vont cesser il n'y a pas beaucoup de
textures
c'est comme un jeu mais pas beaucoup de
détails c'est qu'un mince et les
couleurs puis c'est un peu sombre dans
le livre il ya qu' il ya des moments qui
sont comme plus colorée mais je voulais
pas je voulais garder cet esprit de
queue il vit dans un endroit qui est qui
et qui est pénible puis c'est dur de 5
ans de réfugiés c'est difficile c'est
facile quand tu es chez toi tu ta juste
tu fais de ce que tu veux mais quand
t'es pas chez toi tu dois t'adapter à
tout officier a tout perdu là tout ce
que tu as à masser puis il ya des gens
qui ont perdu quelqu'un de proche puis
déjà le fait que tu peux pas donner tout
ce que tu veux à ton enfant où ça c'est
aussi c'est tout ce truc
moi je connais pas directement mais je
connais avec là où j'habite
j'habitais avant et puis c'est ça le
livre c'était vraiment une façon très
très tendre de décrire une situation qui
est difficile mais en même temps tu as
cette touche humaine qui qui avec la
fleur qui y est pour moi c'est excellent
ça ça me dois donner le ton de m'éclater
est-ce que adrian parce que ça a été
laborieux les l'amener de l'histoire est
ce que les personnages sont imposés le
grand-père et savourer un boss et
comment ça se termine par les mots de
christian écrira c'est toujours
laborieux et je ne sais pas comment le
personnage du grand père ses deux
grands-pères le s'est imposé dans ma
tête mais ce qui est laborieux je pense
quand on écrit pour les enfants parce
que c'est un livre que peut-être les
adultes peuvent aimer mais qui est
destiné aux enfants c'est de trouver
c'est de trouver une histoire qui est
porteuse d'espoirs alors là vraiment on
est dans les antipodes parce que bon
l'histoire se passe dans un camp de
réfugiés on peut penser qu aucun espoir
d'ailleurs ça m'a très bien illustré le
compte le côté sombre c'est un défi pour
elle parce que généralement dans les
livres pour enfants il ya beaucoup de
couleurs où on n'est pas hésité là
c'était les mots le dit c'était une
étendue belge gars et j'ai crise donc
cesser belge et et vers la fin de
l'hymne on voit beaucoup plus d'eux
minorité alors c'est laborieux parce que
c'est un texte d'albums et il faut
penser à l'enfant qu'il ira l'album en
même temps est ce que j'ai vu des
commentaires d'enfants depuis j'ai pas
eu de commentaires des enfants et des
parents ou des enseignants qui ont lu le
livre à des enfants et une enseignante
d'ailleurs m'avait dit elle avait des de
tout jeunes enfants 1ère 2ème année il y
avait un enfant qui avait pleuré dans la
classe moi je vous en raconter une
anecdote d'une réaction parce que j'ai
très bon ami à moi qui est comédien qui
s'appelle jean-françois parent dit et
qui a fait une lecture publique de votre
texte et qu'il avait avec l'album
s'était illustré avec sonore avec des
sons qu'ils avaient ramassé tout il à
tout bout de champ il y avait une petite
fille qui était là avec sa mère qui
essaie elle de voir les images et à la
toute fin de la présentation
elle est allée voir les images et à la
regarder jean-françois la jeune
demoiselle 7 ou 8 ans tout au plus et
avec maman et puis il dit cette histoire
c'est la mienne et ça se passait ça ici
là tout récemment ici en fait à
longueuil en banlieue de montréal dont
il y en a un qui vous ça vous avez parlé
du fait que vous avez connu ça au liban
dans votre liban natal d'avoir vu ces
camps de réfugiés là oui on a le contrat
fichiers palestiniens pia tout là après
la guerre en série a dans un gros comme
migration des gens qui fuyaient la
guerre nous ça c'est des gens se
déplacent puis tu vois la misère partout
yabon gouvernement il n'y a pas beaucoup
de règlements donc tu le vois dans la
rue dans des quartiers plus pauvres puis
au liban ont cessé petit tu te déplaces
tu ta contact direct avec
avec ces endroits là c'est pas comme ces
espaces et péter s'est pas perdue
quelque part non c'est injuste déplacée
ouais c'est toujours pareil ça va
changer
puis c'est m c'est comme ça fait
longtemps que la guerre au liban tout ce
qui est passé c'est toujours comme dans
mon dans mon quotidien
voyons donc c'est comme si quelque chose
comme habituel pour moi à ce point ouais
ouais c'est quand on a vécu la guerre on
s'est déplacé on a failli mourir
plusieurs fois il ya eu les invasions
israéliennes puis on s'est déplacés
encore une fois deux fois trois fois
c'est toujours constant dans notre vie
puis si c'était pas nous il y avait la
garde en série k os d'autres champs qui
sait comme c'est la partie
donc je comprends bien il vous ici
maintenant il ya moins de déplacements
il ya juste un hiver c'est ça c'est vrai
ça c'est vrai ouais je ne t'aime pas
même l'hiver si ça se contente de ça
c'est une belle collaboration entre vous
deux oui oui d'ailleurs lucie papineau
au départ et nous
réunis et je me souviens que ça m'a
montré les premières esquisses des
personnages et je me souviens encore la
petite fille j'ai dit c'est exactement
comme ça que je la voyais ce soit mieux
c'était samia grand père c'était
oui ça devient une belle collaboration
et elle va pas sans l'autre
il ya un bouquin biais là dedans bien
une histoire incroyable autour d'une
montre faut aller le voir fois les le
lire
l'enfant qui n'avait jamais vu une fleur
andréanne gratton en est l'auteur osama
misère en mai l'illustratrice 7 aux
éditions de la bagnole mesdames
merci beaucoup d'être passé et bravo
merci